Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 36. Jetzt wieder in schnellerer Folge. Es ist genug Zeit und die Themenlage ist sehr reichhaltig und heute soll es gehen um Grafikkarten. Grafikkarten und 3D, ein Blick ein wenig in die Geschichte und vor allem auch in die Technik, wie sie sich über die Zeit entwickelt hat. Als Experte zu Gast ist wieder dabei Pavel. Mein Name, wie gehabt, Tim Pritlove. Ja, Chaosradio Express. Ich sage Hallo zu Pavel.
Hallo Tim.
Hallo Pavel. Ja, schön. An dem Thema haben wir ja schon eine Weile vorgeplant und die Gedanken strapaziert. Ist nämlich ein sehr weitgreifendes Feld, insbesondere der 3D-Aspekt. Deswegen wollen wir mal gucken, wie wir uns hier fokussiert bekommen. Aber den Einstieg möchte ich über das Thema Grafikkarten an sich machen. Das ist ja nun mal so ein Begriff, der es auch mittlerweile in den Mainstream geschafft hat. So Grafikkarte hat jeder schon mal gehört. Auch wenn der Begriff Karte nicht unbedingt in allen Fällen angemessen ist. Weist im Prinzip darauf hin, dass das Ganze ja seine Geburtsstunde auch gehabt hat mit der Erfindung des modularen Computers.
Ja, das Grafik-Subsystem, so könnte man das auch nennen, ist oft unabhängig von der CPU entwickelt und gebaut worden. Also beim Apple II beispielsweise gab es schon die Möglichkeit, die grafischen Fähigkeiten damals durch Einbau zum Beispiel der 80-Zeichen-Karte zu erweitern.
Was war denn Standard, 40?
Ja, 40 war auf dem Apple II normal. Aber auch in der Großrechner- und Minicomputer-Welt war es auch so, dass an die Großrechner dann bestimmte Grafik-Subsysteme angeflanscht wurden. Und heutige Grafikkarten gehen eben auch auf ein Grafik-Subsystem von der Firma Silicon Graphics, der Iris 1000, zurück, die im Wesentlichen vor 22 Jahren schon die wichtigsten Features hatte, die so etwa 2000 einen Eingang in die PC-Welt gefunden haben. Aber dazu vielleicht später, vielleicht sollten wir erst mal kurz einsteigen, wozu man denn überhaupt eine Grafikkarte braucht, beziehungsweise woraus sie eigentlich besteht.
Genau, weil grundsätzlich geht es ja erst mal überhaupt, etwas auf den Bildschirm zu bekommen. Und auch ein Bildschirm ist ja in dem Sinne für Computer nicht immer was Normales gewesen. Computerbildschirme haben eigentlich erst in den 70er Jahren so richtig Einzug gehalten. Bis dahin war es durchaus Usus, dass der Computer primär über den Drucker mit seiner Außenwelt kommuniziert hat, wenn es nicht sogar eine Lochkarte war.
Ja, aber dann mit dem, natürlich es gab den Fernseher und was lag näher dann auch als das Prinzip der braunsten Röhre mit dem Computer zu kombinieren und eben nicht so viel Papier zu verschwenden, sondern die Ausgabe des Computers eben auf einer Bildröhre anzuzeigen.
Wobei aber auch die ersten Grafik-Ausgabesysteme in dem Sinne gar nicht Teil des Rechners waren, sondern das kam ja zunächst einmal das Grafik-Terminal.
Genau.
Also die CRT-Röhren wurden sozusagen noch mal in eine separate elektronische Einheit gepackt und die Ausgabe erfolgte durch serielle Zeichenkommunikation mit dem Rechner. Das ist das, was man ja heute noch ganz gut nachvollziehen kann, wenn man sein Terminal-Programm startet. Unter Unix ist das EU-SUS. Auf dem Mac gibt es ja auch die Terminal-Anwendung oder auch die Kommandozeile. Unter Windows ist ja vielen bekannt. Und dort sieht man ja im Prinzip genau diese zeilenbasierte Kommunikation, die ihren Ursprung eben noch in diesen Druckerterminals hat, die dann direkt auf die Bildschirme weitergereicht wurden. Also das Ankommen des Konzeptes, dass der Computer selber in der Lage ist, einen Bildschirm zu beschreiben, war eine Erfindung der 70er Jahre.
Ja, und in der Anfangszeit, als Speicher natürlich extrem teuer war, war es auch praktisch nicht denkbar, wie es dann in den 80ern passiert ist, dass jedes Bit des Speichers mit einem Pixel auf dem Bildschirm korrespondierte. Das konnte man sich damals noch nicht leisten. Das heißt, da hat man eben deswegen bei alphanumerischen Terminals, hatte man eben für jedes Zeichen auf dem Bildschirm einen Platz im Speicher und die Umsetzung erfolgte dann in der Regel durch einen ROM, durch einen Festspeicher, sodass man dort halt für den Video-Speicher mit relativ wenig Platz, mit weniger als einem Kilobyte Video-Speicher ausgekommen ist. Also ein typisches frühes Grafik-Terminal hatte dann eben genauso viel Bytes, wie es Characters auf dem Bildschirm darstellen konnte.
Mehr war nicht nötig.
Und mehr war nicht nötig. Und die frühen Grafik-Terminals hatte man deswegen auch versucht, weil der Speicher so teuer war, noch auf andere Weise zu bauen, indem man nämlich direkt den Elektronenstrahl nicht zeilenweise umgelenkt hat, sondern direkt die Linien auf dem Bildschirm nachgezogen hat. Das waren dann die sogenannten Vector-Grafik-Terminals.
Welche Systeme hatten denn sowas?
Typischerweise für die ganzen IBM Großrechner, die frühen CAD-Systeme, da gab es dann entsprechende spezielle Terminals, die auch mit Speicherröhren noch ausgestattet waren. Aber ich denke, soweit sollten wir dann...
Ja, aber das ist interessant, dass du das sagst, weil ich kann mich noch gut erinnern, diese Vektor-Bildschirme, die haben im Prinzip, wenn man das jetzt mal so mit dem weiteren Verlauf der Geschichte vergleicht, im Prinzip so eine Sackgasse, der Technik-Entwicklung dargestellt haben, waren aber im Prinzip auch schon diese Systeme, wo sehr früh ein paar Visionäre die Grafikkarten der Zukunft, die Grafiksysteme und Grafikfähigkeiten der Zukunft, also ich glaube, das war Alan Kay wieder, der schon sehr früh, ich glaube in den 70er Jahren, mit Vektor-Bildschirme dann eben auch schon tatsächlich, ja 3D war es nicht, aber 2D-Konstruktionssysteme gemacht hat, wo also Skalierung und Verschieben von grafischen Elementen auf dem Bildschirm extrem schnell ging.
Ja, naja, was man damals allerdings nur darstellen konnte, waren sogenannte Drahtgittermodelle. Das heißt, das Problem war eben dann, verdeckte Linien beispielsweise wegzurechnen. Man hatte dann teilweise elaborierte Algorithmen, um nur die sichtbaren Linien zu zeichnen. Aber so richtig, dass was man heute kennt, also dreidimensionale Flächen zu zeichnen, ist tatsächlich erst dann Anfang der 80er Jahre und da vor allem von Silicon Graphics eingeleitet worden.
Ja, wir hatten ja vorhin schon festgestellt, es ging eigentlich so richtig mit dem Apple II. Später kam natürlich dann der IBM PC und auch der hatte von Anfang an das Konzept einer Grafikkarte. Da hieß das dann MDA und konnte halt auch nur zeichnen. Und ich glaube, die erste wirkliche Bitmap-Grafikkarte, wo also jeder einzelne Pixel auf dem Bildschirm als solcher auch angesteuert werden konnte, war die berühmte Hercules Graphics Card. Oder auch Hercules Card, wie sie dann alle einfach nur kurz nannten.
Ja, und die auch dann bunt war, die dann schon bereits Farben anzeigen konnte. Ansonsten, der erste Rechner, zwar ohne Grafikkarte, aber mit einem sogenannten Bitmap-Screen war halt der Mac, wo man dann darauf gesetzt hatte, also der Apple II hatte auch einen Grafikmodus. Man konnte die Apple II-Grafik auch in den sogenannten Grafikmodus umschalten, wo man dann auch einzelne Pixel umschalten konnte. Normalerweise bootete der Apple ja im sogenannten Textmodus und wenn man dann in den Grafikmodus umschaltete, Leute, die das noch kennen, können sich vielleicht noch daran erinnern, dass das Umschalten in dem Grafikmodus meist damit einherging, dass wie so eine Jalousie dann so der Bildschirm gelöscht wurde, was wiederum daran lag, dass beim Apple II man die Adressleitung ein bisschen vertauscht hatte für den Bipmap-Screen, sodass man noch in Assembler, wenn man einen Pixel setzen wollte, noch ein bisschen Bit- arithmetik betreiben musste, um rauszufinden, wo denn tatsächlich jetzt hinter welcher Adresse sich welcher Pixel verbarg, weil das war nicht so, dass die wie etwa beim Mac dann einfach linear im Speicher lagen. Das heißt, dass der Bildpunkt oben links in der Ecke bei der ersten Grafikspeicheradresse und der Bildpunkt unten rechts an der letzten Grafikspeicheradresse lag und ansonsten eben, wenn man sich im Adressraum fortbewegt hat, man eben zeilenweise, ja, Bildelemente adressiert hat. Interessant war, auch wieder weil Speicher teuer war, dass man noch keine Graustufen benutzt hat oder Farben, sondern dass 8-bit, denn 8-Pixeln auf dem Bildschirm entsprochen haben beim beim ersten Mac etwa.
Und auch bei der Herkuleskarte.
Und ja, bei der Herkuleskarte weiß ich gar nicht, da war es etwas komplizierter noch, also auch allein dort den Grafikspeicher zu adressieren. Da hatte man nicht unbedingt einen Direktzugriff, sondern musste dann über bestimmte Register noch Dinge Voodoo machen. Wobei sich das durchzog, bis dann zur vermutlich allen noch bekannten VGA-Standard, dem Video-Graphics-Adapter, der dann beim PC Eingang gehalten hat. Auch da war es tatsächlich sehr mühsam, auf einzelne Pixel zuzugreifen. Da gab es sehr viele Möglichkeiten und das entsprechend zu beschleunigen brauchte dann auch sehr viel Hirnschmalz. Gut, vielleicht ein Ding noch zum Prinzip, wie jetzt so ein Pixel auf den Bildschirm gelangt. Ich sag mir schon, im Prinzip hat man diesen Grafikspeicher auch Framebuffer genannt und dieser Framebuffer wird periodisch ausgelesen. Von einer, aber nicht von der CPU, sondern von der sogenannten Videologik. Die greift auf den Speicher zu und holt sich eben eine Adresse, wandelt das Ganze dann in ein elektrisches Signal um und liest aber dadurch permanent den Speicher. Das gab bei frühen Systemen auch noch das Problem, dass wenn jetzt die CPU auf den Grafikspeicher zugegriffen hat, dass eventuell die Videologik zu dem Zeitpunkt nicht auf den Grafikspeicher zugreifen konnte, so dass man, wenn man das nicht ordentlich synchronisiert hat, worum man sich auch selber kümmern musste, man dann merkwürdige Aussetzer, also so eine Art Bildrauschen hatte in den Momenten, wo man dann auf den Videospeicher von der CPU zugegriffen hat.
Also heutige Grafikkarten haben ja ihren Speicher separat, in der Regel, also auch nicht immer?
Ja, interessanterweise kehrte dann irgendwann auch wieder das Prinzip zurück. Mittlerweile ist es aber heutzutage alles synchronisiert und die Speicher haben ausreichende Bandbreiten. Inzwischen ist auch bequem die Bildausleselogik und die CPU darauf zugreifen können, wobei sich auch ein kleiner Vorgriff, heutige Grafikadapter im Wesentlichen darin unterscheiden, dass die etwas teureren Grafikadapter oder Grafikkarten ihren eigenen Speicher haben, während die billigeren den Hauptspeicher mit benutzen.
Was natürlich eine Menge Kosten spart, weil man muss halt nicht noch mal Fettramm draufhauen und bei den hohen Bildschirmauflösungen, die es heute gibt, ist das ja auch nicht gerade wenig.
Ja, es spart Geld, kostet aber definitiv auch einfach Leistung.
Ja, also im Prinzip war ja mit VGA, abgesehen jetzt von einer ersträbenswerten höheren Auflösung, das 2D-Thema, damit aber eigentlich schon gegessen. Man konnte halt jeden Pixel ansteuern und man konnte dann auch jedem Pixel eine Farbe geben, dann immer so mit der Zeit dann auch noch einen aufsteigenden, höheren Farbauflösung. Am Anfang gab's halt 8-Bit, dann 16-Bit. Mittlerweile sind 32-Bit da eigentlich normal. Und ja, irgendwann setzte halt der Bedarf nach 3D ein. Natürlich erst mal im High-End-Bereich, Personalcomputer-Bereich eigentlich erst mal noch so gar nicht, weil ich glaube, es gab halt auch einfach gar nicht so den Bedarf danach.
Ja, der Bedarf beziehungsweise es war halt zu teuer zunächst und war dann doch der Workstation-Ecke vorbehalten. Das heißt, wenn man ordentlich 3D-Anwendungen, CAD-Anwendungen machen wollte, dann hat man in der Regel zu Workstations gegriffen, die dort dann auch entsprechend hochaufgelöste Farbbildschirme hatten, die damals schon 24-Bit-Farben, also so Ende der 80er-Jahre, waren halt bei Workstations 1280 x 1024, eine gängige Bildschirmauflösung, die hat man bei PCs noch von geträumt. Das war undenkbar, da hatte man bei Workstations aber schon ordentliche 20-Zoll-Bildschirme mit einer vernünftigen Auflösung, so wie man das heute kennt.
Allerdings auch mit einem Preisrahmen, den man sich nicht erwünscht hat.
Ja, das ging dann typischerweise so damals bei 50.000 DM etwa los, wenn man was ordentliches haben wollte und ging dann so bis in die 500.000 DM-Preiskategorie hoch. Wir haben diese Rechner damals Erwachsenencomputer genannt und es war schon sehr luxuriös damals, also für eine Person natürlich, weil es war ein Bildschirm und eine Person, die dann aber ein 500.000 Marks-Rechner hatte, der den Bildschirm versorgt, das war schon sehr...
Ja, da gab es ja auch, wie du schon gesagt hast, diese Unterscheidung, Begriff Workstation, definierte damals eine ganz eigene Computerklasse, der ist heute so ein bisschen gestorben, weil eigentlich auch das, was man damals so an, ich brauche High-Performance für eine Person, das ist halt jetzt eigentlich bei PCs normal, selten, dass man wirklich noch mal eine andere Computerklasse vorschreiten muss für eine bestimmte Anwendung.
Ja, wobei Workstations heute besser ausgestattet PCs sind, in der Regel, die dann speziell zertifizierte Grafikkarten haben für den professionellen Bereich, aber eigentlich...
Damals war es aber alles Unix, da haben sich dann so Hersteller wie Apollo, natürlich Silicon Graphics, die am meisten Erfolg hatten und die eigentlich auch wegweisend waren, lange, lange Zeit. Ich glaube, HP hatte auch noch so ein paar grafikorientierte Workstations, die haben auch später Apollo gekauft. Ist ja auch alles egal. Silicon Graphics war auf jeden Fall sehr erfolgreich mit ihren Iris-Systemen und das hat ja vorhin schon gesagt, dass die Grafikkarte, oder zumindest das Grafik-Subsystem, was in diesen Maschinen drin war, war keine separate Steckkarte oder so.
Nee, das war nur ein Schrank. Die Iris 1000 war so ein kleiner Schrank, der halt neben dem Rechner, also als Zusatz zum Deck-Rechner und erst mit der Iris 2000 haben sie dann auch eigene CPUs gebaut.
Also es waren erst sozusagen separate Grafik-Module für Wix-Computer und später dann eigene Grafik-Workstations. Und Silicon Graphics ging ja auch schon relativ früh in diesen 3D-Bereich.
Ja, die haben, also was das Besondere war, war, dass sie einen speziellen Baustein, also eigentlich die ersten GPUs, wenn man so will, wobei die aus ziemlich vielen Chips allerdings dann schon hoch.
Also Graphics, Processor Unit im Vergleich zu der normalen CPU.
Ja, und was die eben erfunden haben, wenn man so will, ist die sogenannte, heute würde man sie einordnen, die Fixed Function Pipeline, das was man bis, sagen wir, etwa bis 2002, 2003 so als 3D-Grafik kannte. Die wurde eben von Silicon Graphics im Rahmen von einem ARPA-Projekt entwickelt und in Hardware gegossen. Und was diese Systeme dann ausgewiesen hat, war erst mal eine spezielle Hardware, um 3D-Transformationen durchzuführen. Also ein wichtiges Ding, wenn man 3D-Grafik macht heute, ist, dass man Vektoren mit 4x4-Matrizen multiplizieren kann. Das ist so eine wichtige Grundeigenschaft, also schnelle Matrix-Multiplikationen. Und das haben die in Hardware gegossen mit CPUs. CPUs waren damals vergleichsweise langsam, um so etwas durchzuführen. Und das war also der eine Teil eben Schnelle.
Warum 4x4? Also wenn ich jetzt 3D denke, dann denke ich an x, y, z. Das heißt, ich habe zusätzlich zu der normalen 2D-Information noch eine Raumtiefe. Wozu braucht man jetzt 4x4?
Ja, das ist einfach nur der Bequemlichkeit halber, wenn man mit sogenannten homogenen Koordinaten rechnet, also statt 3, die ausreichen würden, 4 Werte nimmt und eine 4x4-Matrix, dann kann man alle Transformationen, die man gerne machen möchte, mit so einer 4x4-Matrix ausdrücken, insbesondere die Translation, also vielleicht auch ein kleiner Ausflug. Man kann, ja und die Projektion auch noch. Das heißt, was man in so eine 4x4-Matrix ausdrücken oder kodieren kann, ist einmal eine Skalierung, also vergrößern oder verkleinern, eine Rotation um eine beliebige Achse und eine Verschiebung. Das ist dann die Translation. Genau, das alles kann man in einem Matrix hineinrechnen und man kann eben immer wieder, also rotieren, skalieren, translieren und alles, das Ergebnis landet wieder in einer 4x4-Matrix.
Der vierte Wert, was macht der dann? Also ich meine, was drückt der aus?
Na, da kann man sich mal anschauen, was das bedeutet. Beispielsweise steckt in den vierten Werten dann, wenn man die so interpretiert, die Translation beispielsweise mit drin. Aber ja, das ist einfach lineare Algebra. Das kommt einfach so raus. Das ist nicht alles unbedingt anschaulich, aber es funktioniert.
Okay, wir wollen ja auch kein Mathe-Podcast machen. Also halten wir einfach mal fest, dass es die Schematik, nach der man dort vorgeht und die ARIX-Grafikkarten oder die Grafik-Zubsysteme dieser Maschinen hatten das sozusagen schon built in. Das heißt, man konnte diese ganzen Matrix-Operationen durch die Hardware durchführen lassen und musste die CPU damit nicht belasten.
Genau, man steckte einfach ein Vektor rein und dann gab es eine Unit, die hat einfach die Matrizen-Multiplikation durchgeführt und dann kam eben ein transformierter Vektor oder Punkt dabei raus. So, das ist der eine Teil. Also man muss sich das vielleicht so vorstellen, wenn man jetzt eine 3D-Szene beschreibt, dann arbeitet man in einem kathesischen Koordinatensystem. Das heißt, jeder Punkt hat eine Koordinate im Raum x, y, z. Und aus diesen Punkten, wenn ich zwei Punkte habe und die miteinander verbinde, dann habe ich eine Linie im 3D-Raum, habe ich drei Punkte, kann ich zum Beispiel ein Dreieck im Raum damit definieren.
Und damit auch eine Fläche.
Und eine Fläche, die kann dann eine beliebige Lage und Orientierung im Raum einnehmen. So beschreibe ich eben erstmal meine 3D-Szenerie. Das heißt, eine 3D-Szene besteht zunächst mal aus einer Reihe von Punkten im Raum. Und diese Punkte sind dann zu sogenannten Primitiven, typischerweise Dreiecke oder Vierecke oder Linien oder einzelne Punkte definiert. Und je nachdem, welche Primitive, also das sage ich der Grafikkarte dann, welche Primitive jetzt kommen, interpretiert sie meine Punkte entsprechend. Im ersten Schritt nimmt sie jetzt die Punkte und jagt sie durch die eben erwähnte 4x4-Matrix. Das sind eigentlich auch wiederum, da passieren zwei Schritte. Der erste Schritt ist, wenn ich natürlich einen 3D-Raum habe, dann kommt etwas dazu, was man Perspektive nennt. Das heißt, ich habe eine virtuelle Kamera, einen Blickpunkt, von dem aus ich in diese Szene schaue. Und der erste Teil der Umrechnung, der dann erfolgt, ist, dass ich aus meinem sogenannten Weltkoordinatensystem, also dort, wo die Koordinaten in der Welt liegen, ich sie transformiere in ein anderes Koordinatensystem, in das Kamerakoordinatensystem.
Und da kommen dann halt so die Fluchten der Betrachtungsperspektive.
Ja, und dann kommt noch, das ist aber der zweite Schritt, die Perspektive in meinem Bildschirm ist ja nicht wirklich 3D, sondern es ist nur eine 2D-Fläche. Das heißt, es kommt dann noch die Projektion, die Abbildung auf eine zweidimensionale Fläche im Prinzip mit hinein. Wobei wir dann wiederum bei einer weiteren Spezialität wären, die überhaupt, die man so gar nicht sehen kann, die so ein bisschen magisch ist, das ist der sogenannte Z-Puffer oder Z-Buffer. Und zwar verbirgt sich, das unterscheidet im Wesentlichen eine 3D-Karte von einer 2D-Karte, dass jeder einzelne Pixel noch einen unsichtbaren Tiefenwert hat, den ich normalerweise gar nicht wahrnehme. Das heißt, es steht dort nicht nur die Farbe in RGB-Werten, sondern es gibt noch hinter jedem Pixel quasi versteckt eine Fließkommanzahl, die mir die Entfernung, also wie tief, wie weit mein Pixel eigentlich von meinem Bildschirm entfernt ist oder von meiner Bildfläche entfernt ist.
War das schon immer eine Fließkommazahl?
Ja, in der Regel schon, oder eine Festkommazahl, aber das war schon sehr wichtig, weil...
Also auf jeden Fall nicht so was wie 8-Bit oder so, sondern es hatte schon eine relativ hohe Auflösung.
Das hat mindestens 16-Bit und in der Regel 16, 24, 32 Bit ist das, was man eben an Tiefenpuffer dort hat. Und erst dieser Tiefenpuffer oder Z-Buffer ermöglicht es relativ schnell und effizient die Verdeckungen von Objekten. Also wenn ich mir jetzt vorstelle, ich habe zwei Flächen, die eine ist näher an mir dran, die andere ist weiter weg und die eine ist rot und die andere ist grün, dann will ich natürlich, dass die grüne Fläche, die weiter vorne ist, meine rote Fläche jetzt überdeckt und teilweise überdeckt. Und das kann ich natürlich vorher auch ausrechnen. Ich könnte halt quasi mein Dreieck, was ich male, was hinten liegt, vorher so abschneiden. So wurde das eben früher auch gemacht. Aber das kostet halt sehr viel Rechenzeit, weil das steigt dann nicht linear an mit der Anzahl der Dreiecke. Und da komme ich dann sehr schnell in Teufels Küche. Und das Geniale am Z-Puffer ist, dem ist das egal. Jedes Pixel hat eine bestimmte Tiefe. Und wenn jetzt ein neues Pixel gemalt wird, dann weiß man, wie weit dieses neue Pixel weg ist. Wenn jetzt aber das Pixel, was dort schon im Bildschirm sich befindet, näher an mir dran ist, dann fällt das neue Pixel. So was sich man in der Computer-Grafikssprache Fragment nennt. Dieses Fragment wird dann eben einfach nicht gemalt, weil die Grafikkarte, die Grafikkarte, der Rastereiser feststellt, okay, da ist schon etwas, was weiter vorne ist. Und wenn es aber weiter vorne ist, dann wird eben das neue Pixel in der neuen Farbe gemalt und der Tiefenpuffer, der Z-Buffer, entsprechend auf den neuen Tiefenwert gesetzt.
Und wenn das durchsichtig ist?
Ja, das ist dann genau ein Problem. Wenn man durchsichtige Polygone malt, muss man diese wiederum vorsortieren und die tatsächlich von hinten nach vorne malen. Also dafür sorgen, dass die Sachen, die weiter hinten sind, vorher gemalt werden.
Ich meine, es kann sich auch mischen dadurch.
Ja, das mischt sich dann. Aber der Tiefenwert, da es nur einen gibt, mischt sich das nicht. Das heißt, ich muss dann, wenn ich transparente Flächen male, das geht, kann ich aber nicht... Also ist mein Z-Buffer eben nicht mehr das Rundum-Sorglos-Paket, sondern der hat eben auch Einschränkungen. Und dann muss ich eben dafür sorgen, dass ich die Dreiecke zumindest in der richtigen Reihenfolge male, wenn es um Transparenzen geht. Weil sonst passiert es, das sieht man auch, wenn man es nicht sortiert. Und die transparente Fläche wird zuerst gemalt, dass dann alles, was eigentlich hinter der transparenten Fläche zu sehen sein sollte, einfach weg ist, weil der Tiefenwert entsprechend abgedatet wurde.
Und wer, ich meine, muss man dann wirklich als Anwendungsprogrammierer diese Sortierung selbst vornehmen?
Ja, muss man.
In allen Fällen, auch heute noch?
Ja, auch heute noch. Also da gibt es, das sind halt die Einschränkungen dieses Prinzipes. Und wenn es um Transparenzen geht oder bei vielen anderen Besonderheiten, muss man halt sortieren.
Wenn wir jetzt nochmal in dieser Zeit bleiben kurz, bevor wir uns ein bisschen mehr der Gegenwart zuwenden.
In welcher Zeit?
In dieser SGI Workstation-Zeit. Also es ist ja auch mal interessant zu schauen, was damit dann eigentlich auch konkret gemacht wurde. Es gab sicherlich Industrieanwendungen, insbesondere denke ich der Automobilbau, der hat immer sehr viel Geld in solche Systeme gesteckt. Aber es gab ja dann auch schon diese aufkeimende Computer-Animations-Szene in Hollywood.
Ja, wobei man gerade bei Computer-Animationen selbst heute noch eher eingeschränkt Echtzeit-Grafik anwendet. Da hatte man dann Zeit, da konnte man dann Minuten oder Stunden oder Tage lang für ein Bild rechnen. Insofern hat man dann auch teilweise etwas andere Algorithmen eingesetzt, aber da konnte man sich Zeit lassen. Interessant war, was dann Anfang der 90er aufkam, war das ganze Thema Virtual Reality, was erst durch diese Echtzeit-Grafik-Workstations möglich gemacht wurde. Da auch die große Domäne der Echtzeit-Computer. Und dann aufkommt Architekturvisualisierung, war ein frühes Thema, Walkthroughs, medizinische Visualisierung, also Ergebnisse von CT und MR-Scans, die man dann dreidimensional dargestellt hat und sich angeschaut hat. Geodaten, also Exploration, all diese Dinge, wo man dann interaktiv mit der Szene arbeiten wollte und eben nicht bestimmte Animationspfade abfahren wollte, sondern mal von rechts, mal von links gucken. Und dazu brauchte man eben Echtzeit.
Na gut, aber eigentlich wollen immer alle Echtzeit haben. Also auch die Leute, die natürlich 3D-Daten modellieren, also überhaupt erstmal die ganzen Grunddaten zusammenbauen, Modelle, Autos, Körper, was es auch immer sein mag, profitieren natürlich davon, dass Dinge in Echtzeit gehen. Also so schnell, dass das Auge keine Trägheit mehr wahrnimmt, keine Verzögerung mehr wahrnimmt.
Ja, also klar für die Modeling- und Animationspakete, insbesondere für Previews, ist es natürlich auch hervorragend. Aber man hat dann trotzdem gerne oder in der Regel Qualität vorgezogen und dann doch die Filme eben eher in nicht Echtzeit gerendert. Mittlerweile heute bei den programmierbaren Grafikkarten ist es durchaus möglich, auch nahezu beliebige Qualität in Echtzeit oder in Echtzeit zu erreichen. Es gibt da etwa von Nvidia eine Software Gelato, die ermöglicht ist, auch hochqualitatives Rendering mithilfe der Grafikkarte durchzuführen mit allem Zip und Zapp, was man gerne hätte.
Es gibt ja so ein paar bekannte Meilensteine der 3D-Animation, die jetzt auf diesen traditionellen Weg wahrscheinlich gegangen haben. Ich denke, der erste Film, der zumindest mit 3D-Optik daherkam, auch wenn ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt gar nicht weiß, inwieweit tatsächlich die 3D-Technik da zum Einsatz kam, ist der Film Tron von Disney. Weißt du da was drüber, wie der produziert wurde? Man hat ja ein bisschen so kokettiert mit diesem Gridmodel und diesen ganzen fliegenden Linien. Hat gar nicht so viel Wert darauf gelegt, jetzt echt auszusehen, sondern da war es ja eben auch ganz bewusst diese minimalisierte Ästhetik.
Also da war es sicherlich eine Mischung aus beiden, aber meines Wissens sind dort auch schon Computer zum Einsatz gekommen, allerdings Mainframes und sehr spezialisierte Software. Aber es ist dann eben auch sehr viel von Hand gemacht, nachbearbeitet worden und mit Effekten. Also es ist nicht etwa ein reiner Animationsfilm aus dem Rechner, wie das heute mittlerweile sogar den traditionellen Disney-Animationsfilm abgelöst hat. Das kam dann eben erst sehr viel später. Toy Story war da ja ein großer Meilenstein, meines Wissens der erste große Blockbuster, auch der erste Full-Length, also der erste Film, der so wirklich in Kinolänge kam, der komplett am Computer gemacht wurde. Ja, ich glaube, da gab es noch den einen oder anderen, die waren dann eher so Nischenproduktionen, die nicht ganz so den Durchbruch...
Du meinst, der auch so appealing war, so ansprechend war, dass er als voller verwertiger Film wahrgenommen wurde.
Der auch wirklich ein Kassenschlager war und der mit anderen Produktionen, mit klassischen Produktionen wirklich mitteilten konnte. Also mit handgezeichneten Animationsfilmen, denen tatsächlich Paroli bieten konnte.
Pixar muss man an der Stelle, glaube ich, auch noch mal explizit erwähnen, weil die ja nun einerseits natürlich durch ihre Endergebnisse, aber auch eben durch ihre Software, die sie geschrieben haben, ganz maßgeblich zu der ganzen 3D-Welt beigetragen haben. Es gibt da ja eine eigene Render-Software, die dort entwickelt wurde.
Die waren auf jeden Fall sehr weit vorne, was das angeht und die haben auch massiv die Fronten dessen, was man mit Computer-Grafik machen kann, vorangetrieben. Da ist auch zu erwähnen, wenn man sich die Historie, die SIGGRAPH anguckt. Die SIGGRAPH ist eine Unterabteilung der ACM, also der Association for Computing Machinery. Das ist die größte Informatiker-Vereinigung der Welt in den USA. Die haben einen Computer-Grafikgruppe, also Special Interest Group, Graphics SIGGRAPH. Das war eigentlich immer der Ort, so jedes Jahr die Weltmeisterschaft der Computer-Grafik, wenn man so will, wo alle, die irgendetwas, die Computer-Grafik gemacht haben, präsent waren. Und das war immer der Showcase, wo man einfach hingepilgert ist, um sich die vorderste Front der Computer-Grafik anzusehen. Und da hat eben auch von Pixar dieser Animationsfilm Luxor Junior, den sie jetzt auch in ihrem Logo haben. Das ist diese hüpfende Lampe. So war einfach damals ein riesengroßer Schlager. Weniger wegen ihrer Computer-Grafik-Ästhetik, sondern aufgrund der Bewegungen, die diese Lampe durchführte und der Ausdrucksfähigkeit und Ausdrucksmöglichkeit, wo man gezeigt hat, dass man mit Computer-Animationen richtige Filme machen kann. Und das war insofern auch ein Meilenstein auf jeden Fall. Der 3D-Geschichte.
Auf dem PC dauert es ja noch ein bisschen länger, bis da Meilensteine sichtbar waren. Ein paar Sachen hatte ich mir ja notiert, aber was du ja gerade gesagt hast, das hatte ich auch ganz vergessen, sind Flugsimulatoren. Die kamen ja auch schon relativ früh. Der Microsoft Flight Simulator, ich weiß gar nicht, war das zumindest der erste wirklich erfolgreiche Flugsimulator, der so auf dem Markt war? Wann kam der?
Ja, kann ich dir jetzt auswendig so gar nicht sagen. Die waren sehr unspektakulär noch in der Anfangszeit. Man hatte ein bisschen grün und ein bisschen braun und ein bisschen blau und ein paar Linien. Das genügte schon, aber es war grafisch zunächst mal nicht sehr anspruchsvoll. Die professionellen Flugsimulatoren, wiederum, da war die Firma Evans & Sutherland ganz groß. Die haben aber keine frei programmierbare Hardware gemacht im Gegensatz zu Silicon Graphics, sondern das waren spezielle Kisten, wo man auch die Firma damit beauftragen musste, die Szenerie zu entwerfen. Also da konnte man als Anwender nichts dran tun, sondern man hat gesagt, ich hätte gerne ein Stück Flugsimulator mit denen und den Szenen und mit denen und den Flugzeugen, und dann haben die das Ding komplett gebaut und komplett geliefert und hingestellt. Aber die haben sie dann auch später versucht, mit relativ wenig Erfolg in den Workstation-Markt einzusteigen, aber da hatte Silicon Graphics mittlerweile so fest mit seinen Rechnern drin und hat dann eigentlich die erste Hälfte der 90er bis fast das Ende der 90er, aber vor allem die erste Hälfte der 90er Jahre des letzten Jahrhunderts komplett beherrscht. Also es gab eigentlich kaum etwas. Und mit der sogenannten Reality Engine, die hatte dann auch so Dinge wie Texture Mapping, beispielsweise. Also Texture Mapping wäre noch vielleicht zu erwähnen. Wir hatten ja vorhin die Dreiecke erwähnt. Also man arbeitet ganz gerne mit Dreiecken bei modernen Grafikkarten als Primitive, weil das hat verschiedene Vorteile. Ein Dreieck ist so immer planar. Also wenn ich drei Punkte habe, dann habe ich nicht das Problem im Gegensatz. Wenn ich vier Punkte habe, dann kann es sein, dass der vierte Punkt nicht mehr in der richtigen Ebene liegt. Und das macht also dann eventuell Schwierigkeiten und deswegen liebt man halt Dreiecke.
Die man auch wieder teilen kann in weitere Dreiecke und die Auflösung zu erhöhen. Wir haben halt dann nur eine Farbe im Zweifelsfall.
Bevor es Texture Mapping gab, wurde das mit der sogenannten VGX-Grafik erstmals eingeführt, Anfang der 90er. Da hatte man noch 256 Kilobyte speziellen Textur-Speicher und eine Textur ist zunächst mal einfach ein Bild, ein normales Bild. Und die Textur hat, der Rastereiser war dann in der Lage, dieses Bild quasi auf ein Dreieck zu kleben. Und das auch perspektivisch korrekt zu tun, sodass sich eben Fotos oder strukturierte Oberflächen wie eine Holzmaserung oder eine Mauerstruktur auf ein Dreieck aufbringen konnte, ohne dass ich jetzt jeden einzelnen Stein als Geometrie machen muss. Ich konnte ein großes Dreieck machen, das hat dann eine Steintextur beispielsweise oder eine Holzmaserungstextur und ist trotzdem aber nur ein Dreieck. Das war also auch noch mal ein sehr großer Schritt hin zum Realismus.
Und die Textur wird dann sozusagen so häufig wiederholt, bis die Fläche beendet ist. Man füllt quasi die Fläche mit dieser Textur.
Die kann dann entweder automatisch wiederholt werden oder auch groß aufgezogen werden.
Wo wir gerade bei den Zoffer-Meilensteinen waren, was ich jetzt mal ganz wichtig finde, weil das ist ja auch immer der Zeitpunkt, wo dann auch der Produktaufbruch dann immer mit gestartet wird. Diese erste 3D-Nachfrage startete ja dann eigentlich erst mit den Spielen so richtig. Ich glaube, das erste war Castle Wolfenstein.
Wolfenstein 3D. Nicht Castle Wolfenstein, sondern Wolfenstein 3D. Und dann aber eigentlich so richtig mit Doom.
Also beides von ID-Software. Besonders bekannt geworden im Zusammenhang ist John Carmack, der da der Lead Programmer ist, der alles Unmögliche aus dieser Computer-Hardware rausgeholt hat.
Weil der arme Kerl eben noch keine Grafikkarten hatte, auf dem PC unterwegs war. Das heißt, all das, was heute die Grafikkarten machen, versucht, mit der CPU zu tun. Und es gibt da ein paar Bücher noch aus der Zeit, wo beschrieben ist, welche Klimmzüge man machen musste und wie wirklich Assembler-Befehle handgeschnitzt wurden und wie man sich dann Tage und Wochen mit ein paar Dutzend Code-Zeilen beschäftigt hat, also Assembler-Codes, nur um noch ein bisschen schneller zu werden. Und musste wirklich jedes Register ziehen, was man hatte und alle Hilfe dazu nehmen. Aber das Ergebnis, die Geschwindigkeit, die man dann erreichte auf dem PC, jetzt nur von der CPU her, kam an das, was 15 Jahre vorher die Iris 1000 gebracht hatte, gerade mal so eben dran. Also nach 15 Jahren kam halt die CPU gerade mal in die Nähe, was 15 Jahre vorher die spezialisierte Hardware geschafft hat.
Also dann kamen Grafikkarten. Jetzt sollten wir vielleicht auch mal so ein bisschen mehr in die aktuelle Zeit kommen. Spulen wir vielleicht mal ein bisschen vor. Also es tauchten dann so Player auf wie Nvidia und später auch ATI.
Ja, wobei vielleicht die erste tatsächlich erfolgreiche Grafikkarte oder 3D-beschleunigende Grafikkarte kam halt von der Firma 3dfx. Die haben tatsächlich 3D-Beschleuniger gebaut, die erstmals keine Grafikkarte war, sondern eine reine 3D-Karte. Ja, eine reine 3D-Beschleuniger. Und die auch noch gar nicht eingangs erwähnte Matrix-Multiplikationsbeschleuniger hatten, sondern reine Rastreiser. Sie kümmerten sich nur um die Pixel, hatten aber eben schon besagten Z-Buffer, den ich erwähnte, und waren in der Lage, wenn ich jetzt meine Dreiecke mit der CPU schon mal transformiert hatte, dann konnte ich halt diese Dreiecke, diese Transformierten an diesen 3D-Beschleuniger erreichen und der hat mir dann gewissermaßen die Pixel ausgemalt und den Z-Buffer ausgemalt und auch das entsprechende notwendige Clipping gemacht.
Aber damit das dann auf den Bildschirm kam, musste sich das Ding quasi in die Grafikkarte so zwischenhängen. Also sozusagen den Output von der Grafikkarte genommen, nochmal überlagert mit den 3D-Bildern, sodass man das quasi nur draufklebt.
Ja, weil die sich wiederum den ganzen Teil gespart hatten, der in den Grafikkarten drinsteckte, um so VGA-Kompatibilität und die ganzen Textmodi und was sonst noch die Grafikkarten hatte, das hatte man dort einfach weggelassen und sich eben nur rein auf das Pixel ausmalen und Z-Buffer und 3D konzentriert. Und dafür konnte man die Dinger sehr billig bauen und hat trotzdem doch eine sehr gute Beschleunigung und Geschwindigkeit erreicht mit dem Schritt.
Was waren denn dann wirklich die ersten wirklichen vollwertigen 3D-beschleunigten Grafikkarten, die den Namen dann auch verdienten?
Das waren eigentlich die GeForce-Karten von Nvidia. Wobei auch bereits die Nvidia TNT-Karten, obwohl sie auch nur reine rasterreisigen Beschleuniger waren, waren sie doch bereits komplette Grafikkarten, die auch diesen ganzen VGA- und Framebuffer und so weiter plus diese Rasterbeschleunigung und die brachten auch bereits schon sehr ordentliche 3D-Performance auch mit einem ordentlichen Speicher und Textur-Hardware. Das waren eigentlich die ersten wirklich brauchbaren, vollwertigen Grafikkarten waren die TNT-Karten. ATI hatte damals auch versucht, glaube ich mit der ersten ATI Rage hieß das Ganze, die dann auch so etwas wie 3D-Beschleunigungsfunktionen haben sollte. Das war aber das komplette Desaster. Also die hat da nichts beschleunigt, sondern im Gegenteil, jeder, der sich vielleicht erinnern kann, der mal versucht hat, irgendwie ein Spiel auf einer der ersten Rage-Karten zu spielen, das war einfach ein Trauerspiel und man hat dann am besten diese Funktionalität ausgelassen und dann die CPU lieber alles machen lassen, weil die waren einfach kompletter Morgz. Da hatte ATIs erster Versuch ein komplettes Desaster. Die haben nie richtig funktioniert, was so 3D angeht.
Also GeForce hat sozusagen dann erstmal den Weg bereitet.
Und GeForce war dann eigentlich erstmalig wirklich, dass man sogenannte Texture and Lighting wurde, wurde das dann genannt. Die hatte die erste vollwertige Grafikpipeline. Also man bezeichnet dieses Grafik-Subsystem auch gerne als Grafikpipeline deswegen, weil es eben verschiedene Bearbeitungsstufen gibt. Wie gesagt, als erste Stufe halt den Vertex-Prozessor, der halt diese Matrix-Multiplikation und Transformation macht und dann als zweiten wichtigen Teil dahinter den Fragment-Prozessor, der die Pixel ausmalt. Das sind auch zwei völlig voneinander unabhängige Systeme mit ganz anderen Eigenschaften. Und das war auch früher so oder ist heute immer noch so, dass man nach Möglichkeit versucht, beide Stufen gleich auszulasten. Und zwar kann man entweder die erste Stufe überlasten und die zweite langweilt sich dann, indem man, wenn ich nämlich einfach sehr groß dreiecke male, dann hat die erste Stufe, also wenn ich beispielsweise ein Dreieck male, was halb so groß ist wie mein Bildschirm, dann muss die erste Stufe gerade mal drei Vertices, also die drei Eckpunkte transformieren und der Rastreiser hinten muss dann eine halbe Million Pixel ausmalen. Das heißt, der ist beschäftigt und vorne langweilt man sich. Das heißt, es war damals auch immer schon so, dass man die Szene so unterteilt hat, dass die Dreiecke nicht zu groß wurden und beispielsweise die bei den SGIs, die waren so ausbalanciert, dass man etwa Dreiecke mit zehn Pixel, dass man da das Optimum erreicht hatte. Das heißt, wenn jedes Dreieck im Durchschnitt zehn Pixel, das heißt, die Dreiecke wirklich so etwa dreimal drei Pixel kann man sagen, groß waren, also sehr kleine Dreiecke, dann hatte man ein ganz gutes Verhältnis.
Das war eigentlich so ein bisschen Verschwendung.
Erreicht, nein, eigentlich nicht, weil man kann das natürlich nicht frei bestimmen, wie groß die Dreiecke werden, weil das ist das Ergebnis wiederum der Transformation und hängt von der Richtung ab, aus der man guckt, aber das ist wie bei allem immer eine Frage der Balance, so dass man all seine Systeme, all seine Hardware-Ressourcen ordentlich auslässt. Das ist ja dasselbe, wenn ich von der Platte lese, also wenn ich zu viel IO habe, dass meine CPU dann eventuell sich langweilt oder umgekehrt. Und genauso ist das eben mit dem Grafiksystem auch. Im Prinzip kann man die Grafikpipeline auch als sogenannten SIMD-Prozessor sehen, also Single Instruction Multiple Data, wobei bei den frühen Grafikkarten oder Grafik-Subsystemen diese Funktionalität relativ beschränkt war. Das heißt, die waren nicht frei programmierbar, sondern die waren konfigurierbar, wenn man so will. Wenn man sich mal OpenGL anschaut, als API jetzt, dann besteht diese API einerseits aus einer Reihe von Calls, mit denen man Schalter umlegt. So zum Beispiel einen Schalter, der da heißt, als nächstes kommen Dreiecke, oder ein Schalter, als nächstes kommen Punkte, oder als nächstes kommen Linien. Und dann...
Kann man sich dann die Hardware entsprechend anpassen.
Man setzt eben diese ganzen kleinen Schalterchen und kippt dann eine Menge Daten in diese konfigurierte Pipeline hinein. Also dann kommen meine Punkte und Dreiecke in Mengen und dann fällt eben hinten die Szene raus. Zum Beispiel ein weiterer Schalter ist, wenn du jetzt ein Dreieck malst, dann benutze bitte dieses Bild als Textur. So, das ist ein weiterer Schalter. Und so gibt es eben hunderte von Schaltern und im Laufe der Zeit wurden das eben auch immer mehr und mehr Schalter, weil man natürlich mehr und mehr Features hatte, bis irgendwann man das geführte, ok, jetzt haben wir so viele Schalter, so langsam wird es unübersichtlich. Und das war dann der Punkt, wo man dann begann, die Grafik-Hardware tatsächlich frei programmierbar zu machen.
Das heißt, SIMD ist ja auch ein stehender Begriff und hat ja auch mittlerweile in die Prozessor-Architektur, also in die normale CPU-Architektur Einzug gehalten. Ich glaube, die ersten waren, ich weiß gar nicht, wer jetzt der erste war, war das PowerPC mit dem AltiVec oder war es Intel mit dem MMX? Im Prinzip haben sie alle dasselbe Ziel gehabt, dass sie eben ihre Vektor-Rechnung, also Rechnung mit Daten, wo man im Wesentlichen einfache, immer wiederkehrende Algorithmen hat, aber das auf sehr viele Daten anwenden möchte, dass das direkt mitten in die CPU hineingebracht wurde.
Man kennt das von der Cray eigentlich. Also Cray war im Prinzip die Vektor-Rechner, waren eigentlich die bekannten SIMD-Architekturen, die auch genau so gearbeitet haben, wo ich dann gesagt habe, ok, Adira ein und dann hat man auch einen Haufen Zahlen reingesteckt und der Vektor-Prozessor hat nichts anderes gemacht als jede zweite Zahl miteinander zu addieren und die wieder in den Speicherbereich herauszuschreiben. Das ist im Prinzip, ja.
Das heißt, das war jetzt sozusagen der, wo befinden wir uns jetzt eigentlich von der Jahreszahl her?
Hast du irgendeine Vorstellung? Das muss 92, 91 gewesen sein. Da ging das schon los mit den programmierbaren Grafikkarten. Ich guck gerade und zwar. Es ging im Prinzip Stückweise, also eigentlich war die GeForce 3, wenn man so will, war die erste Grafikkarte. Das war 2001, die schon sogenannte Shader hatte. Die waren zwar noch relativ eingeschränkt, aber man hatte da schon durchaus die, das war der erste Schritt zur programmierbaren Grafikkarte.
Bevor wir da vielleicht, bevor wir dahin kommen, was sozusagen das Feature Set der aktuellen Grafikkarten ist, weil da landen wir ja jetzt im Prinzip. Du hast es eben schon angesprochen, GL und OpenGL als Programmierschnittstelle hat sich ja auch auf der iRix-Plattform, also auf SGIs Workstation Computer herausgebildet. Ich glaube, es hieß auch zuerst iRix, iRix GL oder einfach nur kurz GL für Graphics Language war im Prinzip eine Abstraktion für Programme, damit man eben einfacher die 3D-Hardware auch in den Griff bekommen kann. Wir haben eben schon gehört, es gab da eben bestimmte Eigenschaften, die man berücksichtigen musste und dieses GL hat einem eine ganze Menge davon abgenommen. Was ich mich jetzt immer gefragt habe ist, und jetzt haben wir ja im Prinzip auch schon, glaube ich, die meiste der Grundlagen zumindest einmal tangiert, wenn ich jetzt ein 3D-Programm schreiben will, sagen wir mal, ich will mir einen Flugsimulator programmieren. Ich flieg so ein bisschen über die Landschaft, keine Ahnung, ich kann vielleicht auch in verschiedene Blickwinkel reinschauen, ich kann von hinten das ganze Flugzeug sehen, wie es durch die Gegend fliegt, oder ich schau vorne aus dem Cockpit, oder vielleicht auch mal zur Seite. Ich muss halt Landschaften machen, ich hab Wetter und Wolken, also was man eben auch heute so kennt. Wie gehe ich da ran? Also was ist eigentlich der Weg, den ich beschreiten muss, um ein 3D-Programm zu machen, und wie spreche ich jetzt mit meiner GL-Schnittstelle an der Stelle?
Okay, also ich mache erstmal im Prinzip ein Fenster, oder ich brauche erstmal einen Grafik-Kontext, so nennt sich das Ganze. Denen öffne ich entweder ein Fenster, oder ich schalte meine gesamte Grafikkarte in den Fullscreen-Modus und bekomme halt so diesen Kontext. Das ist halt im Prinzip eine Sammlung von States, von Zuständen. Und ja, konfiguriere, also wenn ich diesen Kontext habe, dann kann ich halt eigentlich gleich loslegen. Und dann setze ich mir noch die wichtigsten Schalter. Und beispielsweise, wie male jetzt, also jetzt kommen rote Dreiecke, sage ich dann der Grafikkarte, und schiebe dann meine Dreiecksliste hinterher. Und dann erscheinen auf dem Bildschirm rote Dreiecke.
Und die verbleiben dann auch erst mal so lange, bis ich das wieder ändere. Das heißt, die Grafikkarte speichert auch, oder in dem Fall die AP speichert die ganze Zeit. Aber wie weit kann ich das da reinstopfen?
Irgendwann muss ja auch mal Schluss sein, wenn man das mit dem Speichern kann. Nein, er prozessiert ja die Daten und die landen alle im Framebuffer. Das heißt, es ist kumulativ. Ich kann also so lange Daten da reinschieben, wie ich will. Ich kann halt so viele Dreiecke malen, wie ich will. Die wird nie voll.
Davon habe ich ja nur erst mal ein einziges Bild.
Wenn ich bewegen will, gut. Dann ist es noch so, dass ich typischerweise zwei Puffer habe. Den sichtbaren, der gerade angezeigt wird, und einen unsichtbaren, in den ich hinein male. Und wenn ich fertig bin mit Malen, dann schalte ich das Ganze um. Und während dann mein Frontbuffer angezeigt wird, kann ich dann wieder im Hintergrund unsichtbar malen, sodass ich den Bildaufbau, das Malen der einzelnen Dreiecke, gar nicht mitbekomme.
Und dieser zweite Buffer ist auch in der Grafikkarte?
Ja, der ist auch in der Grafikkarte, genau.
Das heißt, die Grafikkarte ist das Double-Buffering, richtig? Ja. Generell hat sie in der Regel zwei Buffer, dass ich sozusagen immer zwei Bildschirme gleichzeitig beschreiben kann, und man schaltet dann immer hin und her.
Genau, beziehungsweise mittlerweile kann ich so viele davon haben, wie ich will. Ich kann auch 100 Buffer mehr machen, aber typischerweise verwendet man zwei. Damit kommt man ganz gut klar, in seltenen Fällen mal drei. Oder für Spezialeffekte hat man dann manchmal fünf bis zehn. Wenn man so Bewegungsunschärfe machen will, etwa für Spezialeffekte, dann habe ich halt mehr. Und ich kann bei modernen Grafikkarten auch mir beliebig viele Framebuffer machen, die nicht angezeigt werden, um sogenanntes Multipass Rendering zu machen. Das heißt, wenn ich etwa in der Szene einen Bildschirm habe, in einem Spiel, was zum Beispiel einen Überwachungsraum anzeigt. Und ich habe jetzt zehn verschiedene Bildschirme dort in dem Überwachungsraum. Und auf jedem Bildschirm ist etwas zu sehen. Dann kann ich mir quasi auf meiner Grafikkarte unsichtbar nochmal zehn unsichtbare Offscreen-Buffer machen. In die rendere ich rein und benutze dann diese Offscreen-Buffer als Textur, um damit meinen Fernseher in der Szene gewissermaßen zu mappen. Oder wenn ich eine 3D-Szenerie für Druck, für hochauflösenden Druck machen will und mehr Pixel haben will, als jetzt mein Bildschirm hat, dann kann ich mir vielleicht auch einen 3000 x 2000-Buffer unsichtbar machen und den dann zum Drucker schicken. Auch das geht. Das heißt, da ist auch inzwischen eine Los-Lösung. Ich muss nicht alles anzeigen, was ich mit der Grafikkarte rendere.
Um jetzt aber so eine Szene wirklich realistisch aussehen zu lassen, muss man ja mehr machen, als nur Oberflächen zu definieren. Sondern da kommt ja auch noch diese Sache dazu, dass man das Ganze eben auch hübsch beleuchten möchte. Schatten und Überdeckung und so einen realistischen Eindruck haben will. Das ist ja auch viel passiert. Das ist das Shading. Es gibt ja verschiedene Methoden. Muss man das sehen?
Ja, also mit der eingangs beschriebenen Fixed-Function-Pipeline kommt man schon sehr weit, was so Realismus angeht, durch besagtes Texture-Mapping. Also durch geschickte Wahl von Texturen kann ich schon enorm viel Realismus erzeugen. Aber natürlich ein großes Thema oder vielleicht erstmal zum Licht noch. Da hatte ich noch nicht viel drüber verloren. Typischerweise bei der Fixed-Function-Pipeline wurde die Beleuchtung auch an den Ecken der Dreiecke nur berechnet, weil das auch relativ aufwendig ist. Und die Beleuchtung war auch nur eine Pseudo-Beleuchtung. Das heißt, ich hatte zwar Licht, aber keinen Schatten. Jede Ecke dieses Dreiecks hat dann noch eine sogenannte Normale bekommen. Das heißt, die beschrieb nochmal die Orientierung dieser Ecke. Also die Normale ist ein Vektor, der senkrecht auf der Oberfläche steht. Und ich konnte Lichtquellen, ich kann Lichtquellen in OpenGL definieren. Das ist wiederum eine andere Richtung, aus der das Licht kommt. Oder ein Punkt, an dem sich das Licht befindet. Und die Grafikkarte berechnet dann den Winkel zwischen der Lichtquelle und meiner Oberflächennormale. Und abhängig davon wurde dann diese Ecke des Dreiecks dunkler oder heller. Das genügt schon, um einen sehr guten 3D-Eindruck zu bekommen. Auch wenn ich keine echten Schatten habe, so habe ich doch das Gefühl, als wären da Schatten. Aber es sind eben nur so eine Art Pseudoschatten. Und wenn ich richtige Schatten haben will, das ist immer noch, selbst mit heutigen Grafikkarten, nicht ganz einfach. Da gibt es momentan zwei Methoden, sogenannte Shadowmaps. Das ist das eine Verfahren, das würde jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen zu weit führend ist, hier zu erläutern. Aber da benutzt man eben auch die Grafikkarte, indem man dann schattierte Pixel auf eine besondere Art und Weise markiert und dann herausbekommt, welche Pixel beleuchtet sind und welche nicht. Aber das ist dann schon ein sogenanntes Multipass-Verfahren. Das heißt, ich muss eben in mehreren Gängen, in mehreren Rendering-Schritten die Schatten berechnen. Und dann gibt es eben noch sogenannte Shadow Volumes. Das ist auch wieder ein anderes Verfahren, mit dem ich Pixel markiere. Beide haben ihre Vor- und Nachteile und sind doch recht rechenintensiv, wenn man das tut. Also Schatten und insbesondere weiche Schatten bringen selbst heutige Grafikkarten immer noch an die Grenzen ihrer Leistungsfähigkeit.
Es gibt ja die verschiedensten Methoden auch dieses Shading zu machen. Also ich glaube dieses ganz normale Default-Shading ist dieses Gouraud-Shading, richtig?
Ja, also was ich beschrieben hat, dieses Gouraud-Shading ist im Prinzip das Berechnen der Winkelabhängigkeit, also Winkel zwischen Lichtquelle und Oberfläche zu berechnen. Plus hat man noch einen draufgesetzt, um Glanz, sogenannte Specular Highlights zu machen, indem man dann nochmal eine spezielle Funktion genommen hat, die nochmal in einem viel engeren Winkel ermöglicht, sogenannte Glanzlichter oder Glanzpunkte zu setzen. Das ist halt das, was man unter Gorot-Shading versteht. Man hat dann eben noch das sogenannte Fong-Shading genommen. Beim Fong-Shading war der Unterschied, dass statt dass man nur das Ganze für die Ecken der Dreiecke genommen hat, man diese Winkelberechnung für jeden einzelnen Pixel vorgenommen hat, was natürlich wesentlich rechenintensiver ist, aber da kann man eben auch unterscheiden zwischen Vertex-basierter Beleuchtung, also nur an den Ecken der Dreiecke, und was dazwischen passiert, wird interpoliert, oder eben Pixel-basierter Beleuchtung, wo dieser Winkel für jedes einzelne Pixel berechnet wird. Also wie man sieht, es wird verdammt viel gerechnet in so einer Grafikkarte.
Für dieses ganze Offline-Rendering war ja sehr populär dieses Raytracing, wo man dann wirklich so einen Lichtstrahl verfolgt. Das ist aber gar nichts, was man in der Grafikkarte so machen kann, oder?
Eigentlich nicht. Man kann mit programmierbarer Grafikkartware auch tatsächlich mittlerweile Raytracing auf der Grafikkarte machen. Aber von der Qualität her ist das Problem beim Raytracing, dass jeder Lichtstrahl, vielleicht erkläre ich ganz kurz noch mal den Unterschied, beim Raytracing schickt man einen Strahl vom Auge. Man muss sich vorstellen.
Wann ist die Sonne?
Ja, ich sitze vor dem Bildschirm und von meinem Auge geht ein Strahl aus, durch jeden einzelnen Pixel. Und ich konstruiere dann eben den Strahl für den einen Pixel, für den nächsten und so weiter und berechne dann den Schnittpunkt dieses Strahls mit meinem Szenenobjekt und reflektiere dann diesen Strahl an. Und zwar so lange, bis ich der Meinung bin, ich müsste ihn jetzt nicht mehr reflektieren.
Also im Prinzip so eine Rückwärtsrechnung. Normalerweise trifft das Licht ja dann alles bei mir auf, das heißt jeder Punkt, den ich sehe, wirft Licht auf mich und die Berechnung beim Raytracing ist genau andersrum.
Ist genau andersrum. Das große Problem ist, wenn ich zum Beispiel ein halbtransparentes Objekt habe, dann spaltet sich mein Strahl auch noch in zwei Strahlen auf, nämlich in den reflektierten Strahl und in den, der das Objekt durchdringt. Das heißt, es addiert sich dann eben sehr schnell auf und Raytracing ist halt nicht so gut geeignet, um Hardware-Unterstützung, um das per Hardware zu unterstützen. Das heißt, selbst wenn ich jetzt eine Grafikkarte einsetze, bin ich nicht wesentlich schneller als mit einer ordentlichen CPU, zumal die Datenstrukturen sind eigentlich für eine von Neumann Architektur besser dran, als mit einer SIMD-Architektur Raytracing zu machen, obwohl es grundsätzlich eben auch geht. Aber von der Qualität her ist es besser, oder die Grafikkarten sind eben dafür ausgelegt, eher dreiecksbasiert zu arbeiten.
Ja, das ist aber jetzt sicherlich noch nicht alles. Ich meine, wenn ich mir heute so Computerspiele anschaue, da geht ja von der Optik her, von diesen Lichteinwirkungen her eine ganze Menge. Was gibt es da sonst noch so für Tricks, die da zur Anwendung kommen?
Ja, es gibt einmal noch eine ganze Reihe natürlich von klassischen Tricks wie Glow. Glow ist zum Beispiel ein ganz wichtiger Effekt mit, wenn ich einen Scheinwerfer habe oder ein Licht, was leuchtet in der Szene. Oder wenn ich erstmal in der Realität ein Licht sehe, dann erzeugt oder eine Lichtquelle, die hell ist, bei mir im Auge um die Lichtquelle herum eine Art Glühend. Das heißt, die Lichtquelle ist nicht scharf begrenzt, sondern die franzt aus. Also wenn ich in den Scheinwerfer rein sehe, hat dieser Scheinwerfer ein helles Zentrum und außen drum eine Simulation des Auges. Genau, es ist dann eine Simulation des Auges, wo ich einen Effekt, der eigentlich bei mir im Auge passiert, dann auch in der Grafik mache. Es ist aber auch, also dieser Glow ist auch etwas, was man bei Zeichentrick-Filmen beispielsweise, schon gerade bei den vielen japanischen Filmen, wenn dann auf der Konsole irgendwelche Lampen angehen und die dann leuchten, dann wird dieser Effekt eben auch durch Glow erzeugt. Das ist auf jeden Fall ein wichtiger Effekt. Dann macht man noch sehr viel mit sogenannten Particles. Particles sind dann ja eigentlich entweder kleine autonom bewegte Polygone oder einfach nur kleine Sprites auf dem Bildschirm, die man also recht eckige Bildchen, die aber auch sich in der 3D-Szene bewegen und von denen ich sehr viele sehr effizient darstellen kann. Und damit macht man so Rauch- und Funken-Effekte etwa. Dann versucht man bei den Lichtquellen eine ganze Menge Spiele noch zu veranstalten, indem man punktförmige Lichtquellen hat, die man bewegt und dann den Lichtkegel noch anzeigt, also etwa wie wenn man in einem dunklen Wald oder in einem verdunkelten Zimmer eine Lichtstrahl trifft, dann sieht man gewissermaßen das Licht in der Luft, also Light Volumes. Nebel war auch schon sehr früh in GL, noch in der Fixed Function Pipeline drin. Ja, dann pixelbasiert, was auch ganz wichtig ist, dass man immer noch versucht, die einzelnen Oberflächen, die Texturen, dass die nicht nur jetzt Farben ausdrücken, sondern dass ich in der Textur auch wiederum noch Oberflächenstrukturen habe, sodass ich dann mit dem, genau, Beschaffenheit, das heißt das sogenannte Bump Mapping, wo ich dann eben eine Textur habe, die auch ein bisschen tiefen Informationen enthält und die auch auf die Lichtquellen in der Szene agiert, sodass ich etwa einen rauen Stein in der Bewegung auch, also abhängig von der Perspektive beispielsweise, zeigen kann. Dann die ganze Sache mit Spiegelungen, das ist sogenannte Environment Mapping, mit dem ich spiegelnde Objekte mache, wo sich die Umgebung um ein Objekt nochmal in dem Objekt spiegelt. Also etwas eigentlich, was mit Raytracing ganz einfach ist, was aber dann wiederum mit der Grafikkarte man dann ein paar Umwege gehen muss, weil man entweder dann eine Pseudomap nimmt, die nicht ganz stimmt, oder die man dann auch entsprechend neu berechnet, was dann auch recht aufwendig ist, weil ich dann im Prinzip nochmal für jedes Objekt, in dem sich etwas spiegelt, die gesamte Szene nochmal sechsmal aus Position des Objekts rechnen muss und bei einigen Spielen, etwa bei Need for Speed Underground, kann ich, weil die Grafikkarten nicht schnell genug sind, kann ich das gut zum einen abschalten oder eben sagen, er soll bitte nur alle drei oder fünf Frames meine Environment-Map neu berechnen. Das sieht dann so ein bisschen albern aus, also ich schalte es immer ab, weil da hat man das Gefühl, dass die Reflektionen so ein bisschen der Szenerie hinterher hinken. Ja, das sind so die wichtigsten Effekte. Dann versucht man noch atmosphärische Effekte, also zum Beispiel in der ATI-Demo war es ganz nett, da bewegte man sich durch eine Lava-Höhle. Und dieses Flimmern der heißen aufsteigenden Luft beispielsweise wird dann auch entsprechend mit Shadern gemacht. Man versucht eben alle optischen Effekte, die in der Realität auftreten, also hin zum Realismus. Es ist so der eine Trend. Ein anderer Trend ist der sogenannte Hyperrealismus, wo man dann versucht beispielsweise mit Toon-Shading oder Non-Photorealistik-Rendering Techniken zu nehmen, wo das zwar nicht echt aussieht, aber einfach emotional.
Emotionales Shading.
Ja, man die Wirkung erzielt, die man gerne hätte, ohne photorealistisch zu werden.
Also die Shading an sich scheint also ein sehr, sehr, sehr wichtiger Teil zu sein, auch gerade derzeit in der Weiterentwicklung bei Grafikkarten. Jetzt geht's ja.
Ja, sicher ja. Shading ist eben einfach zunächst mal ein Begriff. Wie berechne ich die Farbe und Helligkeit eines bestimmten Bildpunkts? Das ist zunächst mal nichts anderes als Shading.
Na gut, das geht ja eigentlich für die ganze 3D-Szene.
Ja, genau. Und deswegen hat man versucht, beispielsweise in Renderman mit der Renderman Shading Language das Ganze dort ja in eine generische Lösung dafür hinzubekommen und dort eine C-ähnliche Sprache entwickelt, die dann auch wiederum Ausgangspunkt gewesen ist für die programmierbare Grafikpipeline, die wir ja schon kurz erwähnt hatten.
Was jetzt sozusagen der Trend ist derzeit bei Grafikkarten. Ja, wir kommen jetzt langsam in der Gegenwart an.
Ja, was seit einigen Jahren jetzt nicht mehr wegzudenken ist. Und was man da im Prinzip gemacht hat, ist, dass man diese beiden wichtigsten Stufen der Grafikpipeline, nämlich den Vertex-Shader und den sogenannten Pixel-Shader, dass man diese beiden Stufen programmierbar gemacht hat. Das heißt, da ist es möglich, also statt wie bei OpenGL, bei der sogenannten alten Fixed Function Pipeline, wo man nur die ganzen vielen Schalter hatte, die man stellen konnte, treten anstelle dieser vielen kleinen Schalter kleine Programmchen, die ich schreiben kann. Zunächst mal auch in einer spezialisierten Form von Assembler. Dann hat man eine sogenannte High-Level-Shading-Language entwickelt. Das haben Microsoft und Nvidia zusammengetan. Die dann auch unter dem Namen CG bei Nvidia, aber es ist eigentlich fast ein und dasselbe, HLSL und CG. Das ist eine C-ähnliche Sprache.
Was ist HL?
High-Level-Shading-Language.
Das war das, wie es bei Rendermen hieß?
Nein, wie es bei DirectX und Microsoft hieß.
Was wir noch gar nicht erwähnt haben. Vielleicht jetzt auch der richtige Zeitpunkt. Wir hatten ja im Prinzip schon über OpenGL gesprochen, weil OpenGL die erste wirkliche 3D-API war, also die erste Programmiererschnittstelle, wo man eben dagegen programmieren konnte. Aber irgendwann ist Microsoft auch mal aufgewacht und hat festgestellt, sowas könnte man ja mal gebrauchen. Dann hat dieses DirectX 3D gebaut in Zusammenarbeit mit SGI. War das nicht so?
Nee, zuerst haben sie sich selber dran versucht. Rausgekommen ist eigentlich erst mal etwas, das war nicht toll. Das war eigentlich nur knapp überhaupt an der Brauchbarkeitsgrenze. Also während OpenGL vergleichsweise Hardware-nah ist und sehr genau die Fähigkeiten der Grafik-Hardware widerspiegelt, also eigentlich eine sehr angenehme Abstraktionsebene ist, mit der man alles machen kann. Aber man zumindest die schlimmsten Dinge, nämlich sich nicht mit Registern und Timing und so weiter rumschlagen muss, aber ansonsten doch auch sehr effizient und Hardware-nah programmiert. Da war ja bestand das Microsoft-Äquivalent daraus, dass man sich riesige Speicherblöcke zusammengebaut hat, also Kommandoströme, und die dann in einem an die Grafikkarte gegeben hat. Und diese komplexen Datenstrukturen zusammenzubauen war halt sehr fehleranfällig und nur sehr schwierig zu debuggen und auch nicht besonders effizient. Und es war eine unangenehme Vermischung von High-Level und Low-Level. Und dann gab es noch verschiedene Modi, so den Immediate-Mode und andere. Und ja, eigentlich wurde das, ich glaube, bis DirectX 5 war das eine der meistgehassten Arpies und ich glaube, John Carmack hat mal auch einen Rant geschrieben, wie furchtbar das Ganze ist. Und irgendwann hat Microsoft offenbar das selber eingesehen, dass das schlimm ist und ein bisschen neidisch nach OpenGL rüber geschielt und hat dann gemacht, was Microsoft halt gerne tut. Es hat dann eine strategische Partnerschaft geschlossen und hat dann eben SGI umarmt. Und SGI hat sich halt umarmen lassen und es ist SGI so ergangen, wie es eben vielen ergangen ist, die von Microsoft umarmt wurden. Sie haben selber nicht allzu viel davon gehabt, aber Microsoft hatte dann irgendwann die Technologie und die Patente, sodass dann mit DirectX 6 im Prinzip man etwas hatte, was doch eigentlich OpenGL von der Funktionalität her sich nicht grundlegend unterscheidet, kann man sagen. Die Calls sehen ein bisschen unschöner aus, aber eigentlich ist es sehr ähnlich. Und es gibt halt noch eine Menge High-Level-Stuff in DirectX und es nimmt ein, wenn man will, eine ganze Menge Arbeit ab. Man ist aber eben auf die Windows-Plattform festgelegt, während man bei OpenGL eine breite Wahl an Plattformen hat. Und es gibt, weiß nicht, ich glaube, über 20 verschiedene Betriebssysteme, auf denen OpenGL-Implementationen zu finden sind.
Und welche ist das mit OpenGL auf Windows auch?
Ja, also funktioniert auch problemlos.
Muss man das noch installieren oder ist das irgendwie da?
Nein, das ist da.
Das heißt, es ist Teil von Windows auch?
Das ist Teil von Windows, wobei von der Architektur her steckt die meiste Funktionalität im Grafikkartentreiber. Das heißt, die eigentliche OpenGL-Implementation sitzt im Treiber und die OpenGL DLL hatte sich acht Jahre lang nicht verändert, brauchte auch nicht, weil die Fähigkeiten des Grafiktreibers transparent zugänglich gemacht werden.
Das hört man ja immer wieder, dass bestimmte GL-Probleme auftreten, aber es dann doch wieder an den Treibern liegt. Das ist auch noch mal ein ganz spezielles Phänomen, was man immer wieder findet. Es liegt extrem viel Intelligenz in den Treibern. Und es ist ja auch so, dass z.B. unter Linux eben Grafikkartentreiber nicht Open Source sind. Das hat sicherlich viele Gründe, sicherlich auch solche Gründe mit Patentverletzungen. Wenn man jetzt irgendwie den Treibern in Open Source ausliefern würde, stehen wahrscheinlich gleich wieder 10 Patentinhaber vor der Tür und würden die Leute wegen irgendwas verklagen. Aber wahrscheinlich ist es eher so, einen technischen Vorsprung haben, weil man da sehr viel implementiert, was man gar nicht erst in der Hardware drin hat.
Es ist sicherlich auch viel, dass sich nicht in die Karten gucken lassen wollen. An der Stelle, also viele Tricks, stecken eben auch in dem Treiber drin. Das heißt, es ist immer ein Zusammenspiel aus Grafikkartware und dem Treiber, der macht teilweise schon auch eine ganze Menge. Viele Dinge sind dann auch oft viele Funktionalitäten von GL in Software implementiert. Man weiß das nie so genau. Abhängig von der Grafikkarte und vom Treiber sind dann eben manche Dinge beschleunigt und manche Dinge nicht. Das kann eben auch passieren, dass dann eine Software-Emulation loslegt, wenn man bestimmte Pixel-Formate wählt oder andere Dinge. Da muss man dann sehr genau wieder die Herstellerdokumentation sich ansehen, ob man sich dann auf dem sogenannten Fast-Path befindet oder ob es dann plötzlich merkwürdigerweise ganz langsam wird, weil die Software-Emulation einspringt. Aber das ist auch bei OpenGL und bei DirectX genau dasselbe. Das kann einem jederzeit passieren.
So, und wie sieht es denn jetzt aus? Wer hat denn jetzt gerade die Nase vorn? Und was sind die Techniken, in denen sich sozusagen am deutlichsten der Unterschied zeigt? Es gab ja auch noch so Nebenkriegsschauplätze, wie zum Beispiel allein schon mal das Interface, der hohe Bandbreitenbedarf, der bestand, um eine Grafikkarte mit Texturdaten zu füllen, war ja, hat ja auch schon am Anfang eigene Schnittstellen erfordert. Die AGP-Schnittstelle war im Prinzip so ein Beschleuniger, so ein PCI on Speed. Jetzt wird das Ganze, glaube ich, durch PCI-Express alles mal wieder auf einen allgemeinen Level geholt. Aber was ist sozusagen, was zeichnet die Grafikkarten heutzutage aus, worauf muss man schauen, um zu bewerten, dass eine Grafikkarte toll ist?
Ja, gut, also zum einen, wer sind die Player? Das ist, glaube ich, relativ klar. Nvidia und ATI liefern sich dort einen Kopfrennen immer um die schnellste Grafikkarte. Wobei, so nach meiner Einschätzung, Nvidia diejenigen sind, die etwas innovativer sind. ATI ist vielfach pragmatischer. Die sind in manchen Stellen technisch ein bisschen hinterher, aber gucken dann etwas besser auf den Leistungsverbrauch oder schaffen es, ihre Chips etwas preiswerter zu fertigen. Ich bin da eher nach wie vor ein Freund mehr von Nvidia. Ich tendiere dann doch mehr zu den Nvidia-Karten. Auch die Treiberqualität, gut unter Windows, unterscheiden sie sich nicht allzu sehr, aber unter anderen Plattformen, also unter Linux zum Beispiel, da hat Nvidia traditionell verwendet da dieselbe Code-Basis. Das heißt, die Windows-Treiber und die Linux-Treiber sind praktisch identisch, man kann auch dort alle Features nutzen, deswegen sind mir die dort auch sympathischer. Aber da hat ATI auch nachgezogen, eine Zeit lang haben sie überhaupt gar keine Linux-Treiber gehabt, da haben sie erst, ich glaube, vor zwei, drei Jahren überhaupt mit angefangen. Und ja, das vielleicht zum einen. Ansonsten unterscheiden sie sich insgesamt von der Leistung. Also mal ist der eine in einem bestimmten Feature schneller, mal der andere. Grundsätzlich sind Grafikkarten unglaublich schnell heute. Also das ist, wenn man sich das anschaut, welche Größenordnung das mittlerweile angenommen hat, also angefangen bei der Transistorzahl, wo seit Jahren die Grafikkarten gerne die Zahl, also die GPUs von der Transistorzahl her, die CPUs, gerne übertreffen, ist es so, dass ja, beispielsweise so eine aktuelle GeForce 7900, beispielsweise erst mal mit 512 MB Grafikspeicher daherkommt, was für sich schon mal ein Hammer ist.
Das haben auch Laptops seelenmäßig, teilweise Tage.
Ja, und das eben allein nur für Grafikzwecke. Und dann bei der Zahl etwa der Vertices, die man da reinstopfen kann, geht das in die, ich glaube so etwa 300 Millionen, das heißt ich kann halt eben etwa 100 Millionen Dreiecke pro Sekunde mit so einer Grafikkarte. Und 100 Millionen Dreiecke muss man sich überlegen, was da notwendig ist. Alleine in der Fixed-Function-Pipeline muss ich halt 300 Millionen Matrizen-Multiplikation, also 4 Matrix-Multiplikationen durchführen.
Um ein einziges Bild anzusetzen?
Nee, ich kann. Die CPU kann 300 Millionen. Allein jetzt nur oft in der ersten Stufe in meinem Vertex-Shader. Und wenn man das mit einer CPU nachprogrammiert, also eine aktuelle High-End-CPU, schafft etwa im Vergleich 10 Millionen. Das heißt, allein in der ersten Stufe habe ich schon den Faktor 30 etwa. Aber dann kommen halt noch die sogenannten Pixel-Shader. Und auch da kann ich, also das ist die sogenannte Fill-Rate, also wie viel Pixel kann ich eigentlich anfassen. Und bei den aktuellen Karten sind es über eine Milliarde Pixel. Da muss man sich mal überlegen, pro Sekunde, die ich anfassen kann. Wenn jetzt mein Bildschirm 1000 Pixel hat, bei einem 1000 mal 1000 Bildschirm jetzt mal Durchschnitt, habe ich eine Million sichtbare Pixel auf dem Bildschirm. Und kann halt aber eine Milliarde Pixel bemalen. Das heißt, ich kann eigentlich von der reinen Pixel-Power 1000 Mal in der Sekunde meinen Bildschirm vollschreiben, wenn ich das will.
Wenn das irgendwas nutzen würde. Das ist ja zumindest schon mal ein Vorteil. Also bei Spielen ist das natürlich ganz wichtig. Aber auch generell will man natürlich auf jeden Fall schon mal eine hohe Wechselfrequenz haben. Also 100 Hz ist auf jeden Fall erstrebenswert.
Ja. Und gut, man hat auch, muss auch sehen, wenn ich so eine Szene male, dann habe ich auch einen Overdraw. Das heißt, ich habe auch verdeckte Flächen. Das heißt, ich muss jedes Pixel tatsächlich in der Szene mehrmals übermalen, weil ich halt vorher nicht weiß, welche Fläche jetzt vorne ist und welche hinten. Und wenn ich eben besagtes Sortieren vermeiden will, dann habe ich halt eben dieses Overdraw. Insofern ist es so, dass Grafikkarten sind halt gut wie generell. Rechner sind eben immer zu langsam. So ist das bei Grafikkarten auch. Wobei, es gab mal in der Frühzeit, so in den 90ern, der Spruch, what is reality? 100 million polygons per second. Und mittlerweile sind wir da. Gut, man weiß, es gibt immer noch einen gewissen Abstand. Also wir haben Reality immer noch nicht erreicht, aber es liegt jetzt nicht mehr unbedingt allein an den Grafikkarten. Aber wir kommen eben immer mehr in die Nähe. Und gut, eine Vision ist eben das sogenannte Cinematic Computing. Das heißt, das, was aus meiner Grafikkarte herausfällt, ununterscheidbar ist von dem, was etwa eine Videokamera, die ich irgendwo in die Welt halte, mir liefert, sodass ich eben von der Realität ununterscheidbare Bilder habe.
Und wie weit sind wir davon noch entfernt?
Naja, schwer zu sagen. Das Auge ist schon sehr gut darin, einfach Unterschiede zu entdecken und die Realität ist dann im Zweifelsfall doch sehr subtil, ich würde sagen. Es hängt von der Szene ab, aber wir kommen immer näher dran und das ist eigentlich absehbar. Aber die Schwierigkeiten beginnen halt jetzt an anderen Stellen zu liegen, nicht nur in der reinen Grafik, sondern halt bei der Rechenleistung, sondern die Physik, das physikalische Modell dahinter und Bewegungen und wie sich die Dinge so beeinflusst. Es gibt sicherlich Szenen mittlerweile, wenn man sich in kontrollierten Szenarien bewegt, da ist es tatsächlich ununterscheidbar. Aber generell sind wir doch noch ein Stück davon entfernt, zumindest was Echtzeit angeht. Was nicht Echtzeit angeht, gibt es seit einigen Jahren schon. Da weiß man mittlerweile, dass viele Filme oder praktisch jeder Film, den man heutzutage im Kino sieht, zumindest jede teurere Hollywood-Produktion, besteht in vielen Teilen aus rechnergenerierten Bildern, die man nicht unterscheiden kann oder die man einfach als Realität akzeptiert. Und da ist es schon erreicht, auf jeden Fall. Das heißt, es ist...
Es ist noch nicht der virtuelle Schauspieler, aber zumindest kann man schon eine ganze Menge auch ausbügeln an Fehlern.
Wobei, man hat auch tatsächlich einen virtuellen Schauspieler mit allem Zip und Zapp von ein paar Jahren gemacht, der schon zumindest nicht erkennbar virtuell war. Man hat wirklich alles abgenommen von einem realen Menschen, seine ganze Bewegung, Gestik...
War der komplett modelliert, oder war das jetzt so ein Wiederauferstandener Tod?
Nee, der war... Man hat schon eine reale Person als Vorbild genommen, aber das, was die Person dann gemacht hat, das war komplett rechnergeneriert. Und für meinen Eindruck war es so, man hat nicht erkannt, dass es sich um eine rechnergenerierte Person gehandelt hat. Aber als Schauspieler war jetzt nicht besonders brillant. Also man hatte jetzt nicht das Gefühl, also auch da fehlten...
War das eine bekannte Person? Ich hab irgendwas in Erinnerung.
Ja, es gab auch natürlich diese Geschichte, diese Vorstellung, diesen Wunsch, irgendwie Humphrey Bogart und Marilyn Monroe uns so auferstehen zu lassen. Aber da ist man, glaube ich, noch ein ganzes Stück von entfernt.
Das ist ja dann aber auch wirklich das höchste Maß an Subtilität, was man da ausdruckbringen muss.
Ja, also was halt so ein bisschen fehlte, war eben genau diese Subtilität, er kam ein bisschen hölzern rüber. Also auch im Vergleich, man hatte die echte Person und die Computergenerierte und man hatte das Gefühl, die Computergenerierte ist einfach ein schlechterer Schauspieler als die reale Person. Also es fehlte noch so ein bisschen etwas, was man zwar nicht genau beziffern oder nicht genau benennen konnte, aber ja.
Ja, das wär jetzt so ein schönes Ende gewesen, aber ich will jetzt noch mal einen Aspekt aufgreifen zum Schluss. Du hast ja schon gesagt, die Grafikkarten sind den normalen CPUs in der reinen Rechenleistung schon weit überlegen. Da fragt man sich ja eigentlich, warum eigentlich die CPUs da nicht so gut mithalten können.
Ja gut, da ist der Grund, die sind halt spezialisiert für eine bestimmte Aufgabe. Das heißt, diese SIMD-Architektur hat halt bestimmte Vorteile. Es ist besser parallelisierbar, weil ich mir aus dem Datenstrom, also ich habe halt im Datenstrom unabhängige Elemente. Ich muss also nicht auf Abhängigkeiten achten, sondern ich kann einfach die Daten an meine 16 Einheiten so verteilen, wer gerade Zeit hat und braucht mich eben, um viele Dinge nicht zu kümmern. Und auch im Speicher mit den Pixeln, das ist eben sehr gut parallelisierbar dort. Das ist das Eingangsspezialisierung und Parallelisierbarkeit und das führt dann zu eben mehr Rechenpower. Wobei, wenn ich ein beliebiges Problem habe oder wenn ich ein ungünstiges Problem habe, was sich eben nicht so gut eignet für die Grafikkarte, dann ist meine CPU noch schneller. In anderen Fällen, wo es besonders gut passt, rennt mir halt die GPU tatsächlich einfach davon.
Es gibt ja jetzt schon erste Bestrebungen. Diese überbordende Grafik-Performance, die ja auch in den allermeisten Fällen gar nicht richtig ausgenutzt wird. Ich meine, wenn ich jetzt in meinem Web-Browser klicke, kann man nicht gerade von einer Überlastung der 3D-Funktion der Grafikkarte reden, schon gar nicht diese anspruchsvolleren Sachen wie Programme ausführen lassen. Ich weiß gar nicht, wer damit angefangen hat. Ich glaube, es war Apple mit dem Quartz Extreme, also mit dem Grafik-Subsystem von Mac OS X. Die haben ja im Prinzip als allererste generisch für alle Programme Nutzen gemacht von der Grafikkarte. Zunächst einmal nur von der Textur-Mapping-Funktion. Also hat quasi Fenster einfach als, in dem Moment, wo sie berechnet waren, einfach in die Grafikkarte geschoben. Und wenn ich die Fenster hin und her schiebe und durch die Gegend bewege, dann braucht man ja den Inhalt nicht nochmal neu zu berechnen, wenn er sich nicht ändert. Und dann kann das eben schon mal die Grafikkarte machen und die CPU ist frei für andere Sachen.
Gut, aber das ist eher eine normale Nutzung der Grafikkarte für Dinge, für die sie eigentlich eher fast gedacht ist. Also Cleverer war zum Beispiel schon die Idee, jetzt von Apple Pixel Shader fürs Frontrendering einzusetzen. Das finde ich schon ziemlich abgefahren, muss ich sagen.
Meinst du, dass dieses Feature, was im letzten Betriebssystem im Prinzip fertig war, aber noch nicht so richtig mit allen Programmen zusammengespielt hat?
Aber grundsätzlich ist die Idee ziemlich abgefahren.
Das ist mehr als nur das Frontrendering gewesen. Das war ja im Prinzip das komplette Grafik-Subsystem, also die komplette Eberechnung Bilder.
Ja, aber speziell, wie gesagt, andere ist eher normal, aber Frontrendering mit Pixel Shader zu machen, ist schon ziemlich geil. Na, angefangen hat es eher aus der wissenschaftlichen Community, wo man natürlich auch immer für alle möglichen Simulationszwecke gerne, also hungrig ist nach Rechenpower. Und da hat man natürlich sehr schnell versucht, alle möglichen Algorithmen, vom Invertieren von Matrizen über alle möglichen Simulationen bis hin zu Raytracing, geguckt, was kann ich noch, also welches Problem passt und mappt halt noch auf die Grafikkarte. Und da gibt es schon eine große Szene, wo jedes Jahr, oder auf der SIGGraf natürlich, aber auch sonst so, man Leute findet, die sagen, ich hab dieses oder jenes Problem jetzt auf der Grafikkarte gemacht. Ganz, also ein Klassiker da, den man sogar mit der Fixed-Function-Pipeline machen konnte, war natürlich Game of Life. Wo man diese Pixel-Power mit entsprechenden Operationen dann einfach unglaublich schnell zelluläre Automaten beispielsweise auf der Grafikkarte laufen lassen kann und andere Dinge.
Ja, die Möglichkeiten sind nicht gerade eine Everyday-Anwendung Game of Life.
Nein, aber die Möglichkeiten sind unbegrenzt. Und gerade jetzt mit den heutigen frei programmierbaren Pixel-Shadern, wo ich auch sehr lange Programme machen kann. Anfangs waren es nur ein paar hundert Instruktionen, die lang sein konnten. Mittlerweile ist es so, dass jeder Pixel-Shader bis zu 65.000 Instruktionen lang sein kann. Also ich kann auch richtig dicke Programme reinpacken. Das ist nicht unbedingt zu empfehlen, weil das natürlich auch Zeit kostet und je komplexer mein Problem ist. Also die meisten Sachen, die ich bisher gesehen habe, die jetzt nichts mit Grafik zu tun haben, waren jetzt nicht so gewaltig viel schneller. Also beispielsweise der Raid Racer erreichte halt nur so Größenordnung 2,3 gegenüber der CPU. Das fand ich jetzt erstmal nicht so umwerfend, aber durchaus interessant erstmal. Aber wie gesagt, man muss jetzt nicht den Fehler machen, zu glauben nur, weil da viele Transistoren brach liegen, dass man wirklich alles damit machen kann. Aber eine bestimmte Klasse von Problemen, wenn die optimal drauf mappt auf die Karte, dann gibt es auf jeden Fall ordentlich Schub von hinten.
Gut, jetzt denke ich mal, haben wir das Thema ganz gut abgehakt. Hört ihr noch irgendwas ein als Schlusswort? Man könnte so viel erzählen.
Es gibt sicherlich noch Tausende von Sachen, aber wir sind jetzt schon ganz gut rum.
Genau, wir wollten ja auch nur einen Teilaspekt dieser unendlichen Welt darstellen, nämlich die Funktionsweise von Grafikkarten und den 3D-Aspekt im Besonderen. Ich hoffe, uns ist das auch ein wenig gelungen. Die Sendung war mal wieder etwas länger, war ja auch mit Pavel.
Jetzt tue ich so, als hätte das an mir gelegen.
Ist ja auch glaube ich kein großer Fehler. Zu der letzten Sendung, wo wir schon so Bedenken hatten, dass sie zu langweilig kamen, dann eher Kommentare. Sie hätte sie ja auch noch ein bisschen länger sein können. Von daher haben wir das jetzt glaube ich auch erreicht.
Ja, Spielekonsolen hatten wir natürlich nicht.
Das ist aber nun wirklich nochmal ein komplett eigenes Thema.
Nicht erwähnt.
Oder ist es?
Ach so, ja. Man könnte noch einen kleinen Ausflug zum Cell machen. Oder die Frage, wo geht es hin, ganz kurz. Zum einen, Intel ist ja nun auch im Grafik-Business. Grafikchip, GPU-Business unterwegs. Nie mischt, nie ganz vorne mit. Aber das, was Intel dort baut, ist auf jeden Fall auch solide.
Also diese 950er Chips, die in günstigeren Notebooks auch zum Einsatz kommen.
Ja, also vor, ich sag mal, mit so einem aktuellen Intel-Chip, da hätte man sich vor ein paar Jahren auf jeden Fall, also vor zwei, drei Jahren wäre das top of the line gewesen. So und auch von den Features her, programmierbare Grafikpipeline und so sind ein bisschen, ja, sind... Ja, sie sind halt einfach kosteneffiziert. Aber ich erwähnte sie eigentlich aus einem anderen Grund, nämlich eigentlich jetzt, wo die Grafikpipeline oder die GPU programmierbarer geworden ist, stellt sich natürlich die Frage, so wie bei der FPU, also früher war ja nun auch CPU und FPU, zwei verschiedene, separate Chips. Warum packt man nicht eigentlich die GPU zusammen mit der CPU auf einen Chip? Dann hat man auch viele lästige Bandbreitenprobleme gelöst und kann tolle Dinge damit machen. Auf die Idee ist aber schon jemand gekommen, nämlich Sony im Prinzip und IBM mit der sogenannten Cell-Architektur. Grunde genommen ist die Cell-Architektur eigentlich genau die Zukunft der Grafikkarten oder Grafik-Subsysteme. Jetzt mal unabhängig davon, dass der aktuelle Cell-Prozessor vielleicht nicht ganz so ideal gelungen ist, ist aber der architektonische Ansatz von dem ganzen, nämlich ein oder mehrere MIMDi-Kerne zusammen mit einer größeren Anzahl von SIMDi-Prozessoren auf einem Chip zu haben.
Also so ein General-Purpose-Prozessor-Kern und ein spezialisierter Prozessor-Kern?
Ja, im Prinzip eigentlich das, was jetzt in meiner Grafikkarte steckt, mit auf der CPU zu haben.
Aber das gibt es doch schon. Ich meine, das ist doch mit SSE 3 oder SSE oder MMX, Altevec. Das sind doch im Prinzip SIMDi-Recheneinheiten.
Ja, aber das sind zu wenige. Die sind nicht leistungsfähig genug.
Also braucht man eigentlich nur mehr davon?
Man braucht mehr davon. Und von der Architektur her und von der Möglichkeit her, was man damit machen kann, sind die einfach noch zu simpel. Und man hat zu wenig Einheiten davon. Und das Programmiermodell ist auch ja, noch nicht optimal. Man sieht also das Potenzial, sieht man aber im Cell-Prozessor. Beispielsweise, ich habe von einer Demo gehört, ich habe sie nicht selber gesehen, aber wo mit einem Cell-Prozessor halt über 50 MPEG-Videos dekodiert wurden. Und das ist, glaube ich, doch die Richtung, in die das Ganze langfristig gehen wird. Also in zehn Jahren, so meine Prognose, werden wir vielleicht Chips haben, so mit den 50 Spielfilmen gleichzeitig. Nein, mit denen wir uns, wenn wir wollen, eher 500 oder 5.000 Spielfilme gleichzeitig angucken oder vielleicht eher so, dass wir halt einen kompletten Spielfilm so schnell komprimieren können oder ein Video so schnell komprimieren können, wie wir es von der Festplatte lesen können. Das heißt, dass wir einfach mit, keine Ahnung, 1.000 Frames pro Sekunde komprimieren oder dekomprimieren können oder einfach auch 3D-Rendering direkt auf der CPU machen werden, so wie es eben mit dem Cell ist. Das heißt, wir werden vielleicht, keine Ahnung, 8 oder 16 MIMDI-Kerne, wie halt jetzt, keine Ahnung, Pentium M, 16 Stück und vielleicht 128 SIMDI-Kerne, die dann so Pixel-Operationen und Matrizen-Multiplikationen machen und eigentlich die heutigen Grafikkarten ersetzen. Und wo wir dann außerdem durch die enge Integration und durch die hohe Busbandbreite dann in der Lage sein werden, Dinge zu tun, die wir uns gar nicht vorstellen können heute.
Okay, da geht uns jetzt die Fantasie aus. Und weil das so ist, machen wir jetzt hier Schluss. Und ja, vielen Dank, Pavel.
Es wird auch kalt. Vielleicht sollte man noch abschließend sagen, das ist wahrscheinlich der erste Open-Air-Podcast.
Genau, wir sitzen hier im Garten ganz schön. Von wegen, Podcasts kommen immer nur aus dem Wohnzimmer. Sie kommen manchmal auch aus dem Garten. Stimmt, es wird jetzt schon ein bisschen chillig hier. Nichtsdestotrotz, wenn ihr Anmerkungen, Anregungen, Kritik und sonstige Hinzufügungen habt zu diesem Podcast oder zu zukünftigen von Chaosradio, dann könnt ihr euch wie immer an chaosradio.ccc.de wenden. Alle Informationen zu den Sendungen und auch insbesondere zu so einer techniklastigen Sendung, wie wir es jetzt gerade hatten. Ihr findet zu dieser Sendung auch immer die kompletten Show Notes online mit allen Links auf komplizierte Begriffe, so wir da eine Ressource im Web gefunden haben. In der Regel immer ein Link in die Wikipedia, das hilft ja auch immer schon weiter. Ja, und ich hoffe, dass es euch gefallen hat und dass ihr auch das nächste Mal wieder zuschaltet, wenn ihr Pavel sagen hört. Jetzt wäre dein Einsatz gewesen. Wenn ihr Lust habt, wieder reinzuhören, dann macht ihr das einfach. Ich sag jetzt mal Tschüss.